bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
sur sociologue hausse alors on est
vendredi donc bien des jours de la
semaine
traditionnel on va dire voilà je
m'apprête à partir pour pour l'institut
où je travaille sachant que je suis
assez libre de mes horaires donc là ce
matin par exemple j'ai j'ai lu des trucs
pour la thèse en prenant mon p'tit déj
voilà je vais pas tarder à partir et
surtout aujourd'hui et une grange en est
puisque je vais signer mumbai
donc voilà je pars voir mon appartement
fin d'aprèm sinon au niveau de la teste
vraiment tout se passe super bien je
suis hyper contente j'ai plein de
séminaires plein de lectures tout se
passe trop trop bien je suis hyper
contente d'avoir d'avoir tenu bond quand
voilà j'ai pas forcément obtenu de
financement au début j'ai dû à
travailler en secteur privé j'ai un peu
remis en cause parfois l'idée de me
lancer dans cette voie mais je sais que
j'ai fait le bon choix et que j'ai bien
fait de m'accrocher parce que je suis
hyper épanouie et heureuse
[Musique]
et je vais prendre cinq minutes avant de
partir au travail pour faire un bilan de
ce que j'ai fait cette semaine c'est à
ce mouvement dès ce que je suis en plein
déménagement mais du coup cette semaine
j'ai participé à une journée d'étude
donc c'est une journée tout entière au
cours de laquelle plusieurs chercheurs
ou acteurs de la société civile viennent
présenter leurs actions leurs travaux
sur un thème précis
donc là le thème c'était l'économie le
développement de l'économie solidaire en
turquie et notamment les dynamiques de
coopérative
donc là où ça m'intéressait
particulièrement c'était sur ce qui
relevait des coopératives agricoles et
des coopératives de femmes
et puis il y avait aussi tout une
dimension un peu plus théorique sur la
littérature portant sur le sujet donc
voilà ça c'était toute ma journée de
lundi donc c'était sur zoom alors c'est
vrai que la fois c'est un avantage
pendant la pandémie c'est que tous les
événements sont accessibles en ligne
donc ça permet d'accéder à des choses
même quand on n'est pas dans le bon pays
on va dire et par exemple ça permet
dessus des événements qui ont lieu en
france
mais l'inconvénient c'est que ça empêche
de pouvoir échanger de manière assez
informelle avec des acteurs ou des
chercheurs à l'issue de leur
présentation c1 paraît pas aussi d'avoir
toutes les interactions voilà de poser
des questions et cetera fins et c'est un
petit peu frustrant mais bon c'est
toujours bien de quand même pouvoir
participer à ces événements
ensuite j'ai continué mes lectures sur
tout un champ qui est en train de
s'ouvrir dans ma bibliographie et j'ai
également assisté à une soutenance de
thèse donc là encore en ligne et c'est
cool parce qu'elle avait lu en france
sinon mais j'ai pu la suivre en ligne
donc c'est la première fois que
j'assistais à une soutenance de thèse
c'était pas une thèse de sociologie ce
test de géographie il ya de grandes
similitudes avec avec mon sujet d'étude
donc c'était super intéressant et là il
me reste deux jours pour finir la
semaine
j'ai pas mal de choses à faire à part en
dehors de la tête mais parce que j'ai
prévu de faire c'est de lire il faut
vraiment que je finisse plusieurs
articles et un livre que j'ai entamée et
voilà du coup c'est parti pour les
derniers jours de cette semaine non
[Musique]
je voulais faire une petite parenthèse
pour vous montrer un petit objet que
j'ai acheté et qui est en train de me
sauver la vie est juste cette petite
chose ici en fait c'est un support pour
l'ordinateur
donc en gros ça permet voilà quand on
est assis d'avoir l'écran en face de soi
et de pas être arquebouté tout le temps
à regarder l'écran
du coup eu en plus à ce repli comme ça
et c'est tout petit à mettre dans un sac
et c'est juste ça coûte vraiment pas
cher et c'est trop trop pratique
voilà pour tous ceux qui passent du
temps sur un ordi portable
je recommande à 1000 %
[Musique]
il
e
[Musique]
on
donc là on est à samedi matin et je me
suis levé tôt parce qu'aujourd'hui je
vais travailler
je pense que c'est un sujet qu'il est
important de montrer aussi c'est que
quand on a en tête on n'a pas d'emploi
du temps vraiment gravé dans le marbre
et que l'on s'adapte assez voilà aux
opportunités qu'on a et c est évidemment
le la flexibilité c'est quelque chose de
magnifique
on travaille vraiment mais le l'autre
aspect de cette flexibilité qui est plus
négatif c'est que c'est à nous de nous
fixer nos propres limites
certes mais qui a aussi des pressions
extérieures qui font que l'on retrouve à
travailler tard le soir et les week-ends
externe et voilà deadline et c est en
fait c'est assez bizarre d'avoir un
rythme d'étudiants quand on est
c'est notre travail en fait du coup
voilà je vais commencer une session de
travail et en plus après je donne un
cours particulier
donc voilà à quoi ressemble mon week end
en tout cas mon samedi
voilà
[Musique]
m
et bien aujourd'hui je travaille depuis
la maison pour plusieurs raisons et
l'une d'entre elles c'est qu'il m'aide
pas si vous voyez leur voix mais du coup
je suis très contente par la neige la
porte c'est un truc un peu sympa à la
période
du coup je travaille depuis chez moi en
ce moment je prépare une proposition de
communication pour un congrès
scientifique la deadline est assez
imminente et il faudrait que ce travail
face à un aller retour entre mes
directeurs de thèse et moi donc c'est un
peu la course mais du coup je suis en
train de tout reprendre ça s'est
compliqué en fait de sa première fois
que je fais et communication pour un
congrès scientifique comme ça en deux
mois une proposition c'est assez
compliqué en fait d'évaluer vraiment ce
qui est attendu entre la part de
de travail de terrain l'appel à part
d'apports théoriques
c'est en plus des propositions qui sont
très courte puisque ses cinq mille 5000
si c'est à dire que ça fait deux pages
et donc dire en deux pages assez pour
qu'ils soient précis scientifiquement et
en termes de terrain que ça paraisse
ancré dans la réalité
voilà c'est un peu prise haute et je
pense à un truc dont on prend l'habitude
il faut qu'on en a fait une finale on
peut aussi utiliser un peu la manière
dont sont à rédiger mais voilà là c'est
un peu prise de tête
donc je rentre à faire ça mais
heureusement il ya de la neige dehors et
ça me rend très heureuse quand je vous
disais j'ai mes documents action au vert
pour préparer le congrès j'utilise
toujours à mon petit support
d'ordinateur voilà qui est vraiment au
top parce que déjà ça me parle de poser
mon poignet et puis ça a laissé un peu
et prendre que ça me permet de ne pas
être au bout sur un ordi et je me montre
un petit peu la belle neige voilà chez
serait un très agréable de voir de la
neige tombée dehors c'est hyper apaisant
[Musique]
ah ah
e
[Musique]
écoutez je voulais faire un petit point
sur les semaines qui se sont écoulées
donc j'ai déménagé première grande
nouvelle je suis installé puis j'ai
passé du coup pas beaucoup de temps à
gérer l'administratif entre bas le
déménagement le titre de séjour pour
pouvoir être légalement sur le
territoire
et puis je voulais vos petits soucis de
santé wade souhaite pas très cool à
gérer et par contre au niveau de la
thèse ça avance vraiment bien je suis
assez contente
en gros je suis en ehpad où je lis
énormément j'ai aussi donc envoyé ma
proposons de la communication au congrès
scientifique
j'ai eu un peu un espèce de ce cru
courau ça faisait des jours et des jours
que je mettais un paquet de trucs que je
faisais pas un détail et des brouillons
machin et en une journée
quand même par en une matinée j'ai tout
fait j'ai trop bizarre en fait je pense
qu'il ya vraiment ce truc où tu as
besoin de maths est cité en place et
sous et puis à un moment où juste tout
sa ligne et là il faut utiliser cette
énergie et foncé j'ai mon premier rendez
vous avec mon tracteur et ma directrice
de thèse qui s'est très bien passé on a
fait le point à vue sur ce que j'ai fait
depuis que j'ai commencé à temps plein à
ma thèse
voilà donc en gros plein de
recommandations de lecture c'est pas
très bon dans la phase lecture lecture
et je commence à vraiment bien me
positionner pour des voilà des
événements à venir et tout donc ça c'est
cool même si bon niveau de la pandémie
forcément ça reste assez incertain voilà
sinon en ce qui concerne sociaux lobos
voilà ça fait je pense qu'avec cette
vidéo ça fera dix semaines que je poste
une vidéo par semaine ça me demande une
sacrée organisation je vais pas me
mentir mais en fait je suis trop
contente pense pas du tout que ça à
rythme que je pourrais garder sur le
long terme
mais voilà pour le lancement de ce lot
bosse je trouve ça cool d'avoir traité
déjà pas mal de sujets différentes saeba
en tout cas merci de de me suivre sur la
chaîne youtube et sur le compte
instagram c'est ça me fait trop plaisir
j'ai des discussions
super intéressante avec certains d'entre
vous et ouais c'est vraiment le côté
trop cool des réseaux sociaux et c'est
un peu bête à dire mais en ces temps de
pandémie non en fait ça donne de
l'énergie de voir qu'à d'autres gens qui
vivent les mêmes choses ou pas
d'ailleurs mais juste pouvoir discuter
avec des personnes de qu'on n'aurait pas
forcément l'occasion de vous de
rencontrer dans la vraie vie
donc voilà c'est un peu le côté cool des
réseaux voilà pour sociaux logos la
thèse balayée en fait je traîne un peu
mais je vais aller me remettre en fait
j'ai entamé une relecture des blagues
féministes américaines qui vont que je
vais mobiliser de manière très
conséquente dans ma thèse donc voilà je
sente pas de relecture de ça j'ai toute
une littérature plus sur le nationalisme
que j'ai entamé là je fais une petite
pause seront concentrées sur black
féministe et je vais y revenir par la
suite
voilà où j'en suis à l'écouté
merci beaucoup de me suivre encore une
fois et écoutez j'ai hâte de vous
retrouver pour une prochaine vidéo et je
vous laisse avec quelques images d'un
beau lever de soleil sur le bosphore
genre sont que la moitié des vidéos que
je prends avec mon téléphone pour
sociaux logos c'est des couchers et deux
levers de soleil sur le bateau au psy
fait des gros bisous et je me retrouve
très vite sur ça sur le dos
[Musique]